hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's been a whole two weeks since we
last had a meet-up to look over the map
and all the changes it has endured so
let's do that now if you're new around
these parts this is the series we break
down huge and minut map updates and
attempt to find the hidden stories and
potential future events and this week we
may have discovered the true identity of
jewels so sit your butt down for 10
minutes press like for more Fortnight
content and please subscribe to help me
get these videos to more people
fortnight chapter 2 season 3 week 5
let's do this the biggest news of the
season thus far is the receding water
line around the map we are now three
stages into the water level progression
and looking around the map the
devastation is everywhere former
picturesque areas are now seaweed
covered mud holes down at Camp Cod the
place which was made to give thanks to
chapter 1 content is suffering the
former dusty diner seat and the og dusty
divot image has been thrown around but
luckily they've survived up at risky
reels the location is now back but the
same issues occur it's a mess we'll
likely see the haulage wagons moving
over the next few weeks to clean up this
bomb site but there's something here the
community are attributed to Midas there
are now three golden cars when before
the flood there weren't any at all I'm
guessing these are a challenge
but legend has it that everything Midas
touches turns to gold we've seen that in
a cutscene and many weapons too so it's
completely possible that Midas is still
alive and passed through risky rails
touching these vehicles in the process
this would mean he's going north from
the agency and towards the secret island
with the hidden bunker on it hmm that
could be interesting but what do you
think is Midas still alive or has that
part of the story being done and dusted
[Music]
sticking with the water level and it's
time to say goodbye to piranha island it
served as well for three weeks but the
trash island is now missing this is a
shame you know because I love the design
personally and the home of the
crustaceans was beginning to build but
now they vanished
they aren't underwater they have
departed but what if they were able to
rescue themselves before the island was
washed away maybe in a boat sailing the
Seas like pirates well if we go back to
another island which arrived in our last
meet up we saw a tribe of crustaceans
move away from the Whirlpool settling
down here with a basic fort and soon
after more arrived by boat to build up
the community well this week another
ship has arrived but this time they are
pirates are they the ones from piranha
island we don't know if they are friend
or foe right now but we do know they can
catch shark fish look at that could
these be the guys from piranha tribe
looking to settle down elsewhere on the
map and join forces with these guys or
worse still have they come to overthrow
the inhabitants all I know for certain
is how much I'm vibing to their sick
tombs
[Music]
oh did she see one of the emotes then
well let's look at that amount now this
is a free mode called introducing this
is currently available right now for the
next month - all PS Plus subscribers I
know that many non PlayStation game has
watched these videos - and I'm cool with
that so don't see this as a flex if this
emote is something you'd like to have it
is possible to get it if you sign up to
PS Plus for a free trial to test out the
service letting you grab this amount and
the contrail and the glider totally free
usually when your subscription is over
with PS plus you lose access to the
games but with added content like this
you get it forever so if you like that
emotes you can still get this no
pressure of course you do you
PlayStation have recently given epic a
whole bunch of cash to continue their
relationship so expect loads more
PlayStation free content soon but I'm
also certain a Nintendo will be given a
bundle soon do you remember back when
Party Royale was introduced did you
notice something hidden in plain sight
look it's Kirby a Nintendo property in
fortnight's this was blurred out in the
version given to PlayStation so I think
it makes sense to expect a Nintendo
bundle soon or maybe a crossover and
hopefully Xbox will get some love - I
remember the first which drops for
fortnight content they were so good so
many people wanted those skins but now
I'm ranting about skins so let's move on
[Music]
going back to the water level and one
more thing which is worth noticing the
pirate ship well it's not a pirate ship
but I tend to call it the pirate ship
when I go there it does not move twice
and I need your help understanding what
the hell is it doing here's the
difference from the last few days the
ship has moved from the center of the
ocean area to now be pointing directly
towards the dam it isn't going to ram it
is it that would make for a pretty cool
map update and it would also dry out the
riverbed for the cars to drive through
next week I think we're onto something
and that got me thinking about the
introduction of land vehicles next week
if we look at the other areas of the map
we can now see the gas stations are
above water level ready to be used to
refuel our vehicles but also look at how
things are shifting around they're
almost making potential roads where the
water is just by the Galleon you can see
a landmass has slightly shifted to line
up with the road it's only a small
change but it's definitely purposeful
elsewhere the no sweat insurance
building has shifted again to reveal the
old junkyard and even more land I'm
looking forward to the water going even
further don't get me wrong I like the
water but I'm happy to see more dry land
how'd you feel about the flood happy to
see it going or do you want it to stay
like this forever there's one of the
area of the map which has vanished
overnight recently half the damn rig
completely eradicated without warning
which means the rig being rebuilt is
pretty much impossible now rip the dream
but the loss of the crane here is
actually a big thing if you're lazy like
me and don't do your challenges until
the very last day over the very last
week of the season you should know that
one challenge involves the crane that's
no longer there luckily epic have stated
the challenge will be relocated and if
that fails we will be given an
autocomplete which is nice did anyone
ever drop here anyway will you miss the
old rig and TN Tina's explosive past oh
I forgot to mention the bog warrior he's
now breathing fresh air above the water
level complete with his own treasure
pack for you to grab all we need now is
for track Saurus to get off his butt and
wake up and by the way bog warrior we
need a better name than this
your thing renewed family named this
monstrosity before he fights the
sleeping transformer remember he's made
out of bats he rhinos toilets that kind
of thing do you think
before we move on to more story related
things have you ever visited pleasant
park in replay mode usually when your
character is far away from a Pio I it
loads in with low polygons but pleasant
seems to work differently Pleasant can
completely vanish in replays leaving
this cool area in its wake
strange strange isn't it usually when
locations vanished like this it tells us
that later in the season there will be a
huge change here but what the heck could
that be of the current glitches which
could impact the map include the purple
water at steamy stacks changing color
for some users that opens up so many
story theories and random items change
color to gold and yellow as if Midas has
touched them are these glitches in the
matrix or is the future storyline being
revealed okay let's do a little story
work have you been to the agency
recently sorry the authority I still
need to get used to that and paid
attention to the walls the amount of
Brutus images here and memorabilia is
pretty impressive but why is it here
well I have an answer but let's first
set the scene jaws has followed on the
ownership of the authority slush agency
from Midas we know they are at the very
least aware of each other as Midas had
an image upon his desk of jewels if that
was a father/daughter relationship like
the one from the Midas fable wouldn't
all these images now be Midas why the
heck is it Brutus and this is doubled up
upon when we see the unlockable skin for
Jules its Brutus is shadow persona
here's what I propose
Jules is the daughter of Brutus and not
Midas I know what you need evidence
well back in season two there were two
offices over in retail Row one for ghost
and one for shadow in the first few
weeks the image was blurred but mid
season we were able to see this image
and I surmise that we were going to get
a back story for the people in the photo
and look who's in the photo Brutus and
Oki I don't know that skin I don't think
it's a new skin do we already have this
one like usual I need help
anyway I think these people are the
parents of Jules giving her a reason to
try and find them why else would she
have such a focus on Brutus and surround
herself with memorabilia like this have
these secret map changes given as a new
theory I'd love to know your thoughts
okay so tell me now what have I missed
please let me know add it to the
comments and I'll be sure to put it in
next week's episode next time we meet up
we will have drivable cars which makes
me think of the days of the shopping
carts man those were good memories
please do me a favor and hit me with
some vehicle myths if on next week's
myths chaser video and above all else
stay awesome to end like usual here's
the legend roll call the leggins
themselves people who are kind enough to
use code atom arrow in the store to buy
something they like and then show me
that in a DM on Twitter thanks for
sticking with me some of you guys have
been with me since the very start I'm
truly humbled I really am if you're
still waiting for our reply on Twitter
I'm now up to July the 7th so I'm about
a week behind my apologies sorry is
taking so long and thank you once again
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure I'll see you on the 21st
with a huge pot night update see ya
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]